all right so since I'm talking to two
great ladies of comedy it seems that
women in comedy is actually hotter than
men in comedy now between Tina Fey and
Amy Poehler rebel Wilson's like the
hottest one at the moment do you guys
think that women that the day of the
woman in comedy is here to stay Melissa
universe I mean I I think it's a
wonderful wonderful notion I'm so
thrilled that there's support from a man
in comedy I mean I think women in comedy
I think women have always been funny and
I think that there's like I asked a lot
like do you think women aren't funny or
what's is there a difference between
male and female humor I think funny is
funny and I think that it's people are
finally realizing that yeah I think
during the 50 60 70 s a lot of shows
were headed by females if you notice and
then it died out after after The Cosby
Show went off it really all just died
out and I'm not just talking about
african-american all-female show gone
female lead show yeah but now they're
back on the rise that Tina Fey is a
wonderful writer and you have to write
your own stuff that's really what it is
this is like rappers singers you have to
now write your own jokes you have to or
have a team that knows you and
fortunately for me I had some great
writers coming up or Richard Massey and
Tracy gamble they used to write for
Golden Girls
yeah and they could hear my voice and
some great writers now our first fan
with Byron Allen bacon here when people
can hear you're 10 like in your show
they write before you which is great but
they you can't write before everybody so
a woman has to write for herself but
we're definitely on the rise but you
know we still have trouble we can't do
like men do you know we just we look
this mean and [ __ ] and it's not good
and that's a shame cuz it would be nice
to be that way not be judged yeah well
we're kind of jump into something that I
wanted to get to you later but I think
this is perfect so you're you're right
so there was like this thing where you
had Lucy and I know I'm Mary Tyler Moore
and all them and all these women that
were huge and then it kind of ya round
Cosby lady Butler yeah gone it just
disappeared now you got a spinoff from
two to seven that it really made the
pilot and then that was it was it a
little bit early was it a little bit
early for a fee
dominated have a showrunner I didn't
have to write politics I know now this
is years later yeah but yeah you have to
have a showrunner right producer and
somebody so my producer two slots rather
than three and so they trade you off for
a better deal it's done all the time
so I don't I don't take this business
personal at all it's never personal
unless somebody punches you in the face
I take that person but everything else
to sticks and stones you know you really
have to be that way and when you leave
an audition this is my advice I know you
didn't ask this to any up-and-coming
actor comedian leave the audition and
leave it right there in the room don't
take it with you into the street just go
home and continue doing what you don't
think about it oh I need this job
coz I've been there I mean I cried over
a job I lost ins recently as um what's
that show with the girls smokes pot she
sells and then she goes with a DEA guy
she's on cable you know I'm talking
about yes we thank you spot weeds like
but you don't forget it yeah beet but I
wanted that part so bad the girl wonders
great you know but I was like crying and
tensed because it was two of us and I
didn't get I usually win I do I usually
win but I didn't win that when I was so
upset and I was morbid for like three
months and then it came on I went you
know cuz I didn't agree with the
material either and I didn't know that
who knew so sometimes not for you yeah
what do you guys think about having to
be sort of sexy in comedy because girls
sort of have to be it's just the way it
is guys can be sort of fat Slaven ly
losers every sitcom is about some
disheveled schmuck who can't really do
anything and he has a gorgeous girl but
you I mean both of you on on on all your
shows and on a big bang now you guys are
sexy even if you come on Eva its nerdy
sexy it's nerdy hot like how does that
play like Sofia I love us fear Vergara
Modern Family I love her you're right I
lied I do like sexy and funny there you
go I mean I think on on Big Bang I think
what they do so beautifully is smart
they make smart sexy and you know it's
not I'm not in anything that's like
super revealing or anything like that
but they they write very very smart
is it weird as an actress
when you know so much of what you do has
to do with your look in a certain way
and then they scale it back for you when
you're on air because you have to either
be wearing glasses or wear things that
maybe you wouldn't normally wear that
kind of stuff we can see she sexes the
other we see a crush on you that is very
exciting to me I kind of like it it kind
of sets the bar low that way if I go
somewhere without the glasses and stuff
and it's like okay well you look a
little better yeah it's better than like
them really damping up and then I go
somewhere else and they're like they
really do a good job for you yeah you
look cute but you look that's what I'd
say that bonobos comes the official
outfitter of the Reuben report enter
code TRR to zero for twenty percent off
your first purchase